COMPUTER-DRIVEN ALGORITHMS THAT
KEY ON VOLATILITY ALSO ENJOYED
INTO THE WILD SWINGS.
SO, WHEN WILL THE MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS BEING AFFECTED IN A
REAL FINANCIAL WAY BY THE CRISIS
SEEK CONCRETE ACTION OUT OF
CONGRESS THAT KEVIN WAS TALKING
ABOUT?
BIPARTISAN OPPOSITION TONIGHT TO
THE RELIEF PLAN THAT PASSED OVER
THE WEEKEND WITH REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS PUSHING FOR MORE HELP
FOR ORDINARY AMERICANS WHILE
SOME ARE CONCERNED OF THE PRICE
TAG.
TALKING ABOUT WHEN WE MIGHT GET
THE PACKAGE DONE, SENATOR AND
DR. JOHN BARRASSO OF WYOMING.
GOOD HAVE YOU BACK, SENATOR.
WE KNOW THE HOUSE HAS TECHNICAL
FIXES TO WHAT THEY PASSED A
COUPLE OF DAYS AGO.
I BELIEVE IT HAS TO BE SENATE
TOMORROW.
WHAT’S YOUR TAKE TO HOW IT WILL
BE RECEIVED THERE AND HOW THE
VOTE MAY GO?
>> PEOPLE ARE BEING CHALLENGED
ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY, AT A
TIME LIKE THIS RELIEF IS
NECESSARY BY THE GOVERNMENT.
WE WANT TO DO IT IT, IT DOESN’T
BURDEN BUSINESSES, THIS IS A
GOVERNMENT OPPORTUNITY AND
RESPONSIBILITY RIGHT NOW TO HELP
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THE WORKERS, FAMILIES, I EXPECT
THIS IS GOING TO PASS WHAT’S
GOING TO COME OVER FROM THE
HOUSE, BUT THAT’S ONLY PHASE
TWO.
PHASE ONE WAS THE MEDICAL
COMPONENT, MAKING SURE THAT
DOCTOR IS IN RESEARCHERS HAVE
WHAT THEY NEEDED.
THIS IS THE FIRST STEP, AND I
WOULDN’T BE SURPRISED IF THE
PHASE THREE ALSO PASSED LATER
THIS WEEK, A MUCH BIGGER PIECE
TO HELP OUR WORKERS.
BECAUSE, SHANNON, WITH THE NEW
THINGS THAT ARE HAPPENING AROUND
THE COUNTRY, PEOPLE IN
RESTAURANTS AND BARS THAT ARE
OUT OF WORK IMMEDIATELY, THERE
ARE IMMEDIATE NEEDS AND THE
GOVERNMENT HAS A RESPONSIBILITY
TO STEP IN.
>> Shannon: SENATOR --
SECRETARY MNUCHIN WAS QUOTED
COMING OUT OF A MEETING TONIGHT,
I DON’T KNOW IF YOU ARE A PART
OF THAT, BUT MAYBE TOMORROW.
HE SAYS, WILL BE LOOKING FOR
SUPPORT FOR SMALL AND
MEDIUM-SIZE BUSINESSES, WILL BE
LOOKING SUPPORT FOR CERTAIN
INDUSTRIES THAT WE TALKED ABOUT
THAT ARE PARTICULARLY HARD HIT.
I’VE TALKED ABOUT AIRLINES,
HOTELS, OTHERS BUT WE WILL BE
LOOKING AT A GENERAL STIMULUS.
IT IS CRITICAL AT THIS MOMENT,
BUT THERE ARE THOSE WHO HAVE
RAISED SERIOUS QUESTIONS ABOUT
WHETHER SOME OF THESE POLICIES
THAT ARE VERY EXPENSIVE GET
LOCKED IN A PERMANENT WAY, EVEN
A MORE PASSIVE CRISIS, THE PRICE
TAG, HOW DO YOU ENTER THOSE
CONCERNS?
>> THIS NEEDS TO BE TARGETED AND
IT NEEDS TO BE TEMPORARY.
YOU HAVE TO THINK OF OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES IN WYOMING AND THIS
IS ABOUT EVERY BUSINESS IN
WYOMING.
YOU WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THEIR
EMPLOYEES ARE TAKEN CARE OF, BUT
YOU WANT TO MAKE SURE BY THE
TIME THAT THIS IS OVER, THOSE
BUSINESSES HAVE THE CASH ON HAND
THAT THEY CAN COME BACK AND OPEN
AGAIN AND DON’T FIND THEMSELVES
IN A BAD SITUATION.
SO YOU WANT TO TAKE CARE OF THE
EMPLOYEES AS WELL AS THE SMALL
BUSINESSES BECAUSE SMALL
BUSINESSES, SHANNON, THAT SUPPLY
70% OF THE JOBS IN AMERICA.
BUT UNTIL WE GET THE DISEASE
ITSELF, THIS VIRUS IS UNDER
CONTROL, AND GET BEYOND THE
HEALTH COMPONENT ON IT, NO
MATTER WHAT STIMULUS YOU
APPLIED, THE ECONOMY WILL NOT
RECOVER AS THE PRESIDENT SAID
TODAY UNTIL WE HAVE THE VIRUS
UNDER CONTROL.
>> Shannon: I WANT TO PLAY
SOMETHING FROM DR. EDWARD BURKE,
VERY WELL RESPECTED ACROSS
NUMEROUS ADMINISTRATIONS.
HERE’S WHAT SHE SAID TODAY.
>> WE BEEN WORKING ON MODELS,
DAY AND NIGHT.
>> WHAT HAS BEEN THE BIGGEST
IMPACT IN THE MODEL IS SOCIAL
DISTANCING, SMALL GROUPS, NOT
GOING IN PUBLIC, LARGE GROUPS.
IF EVERYBODY IN AMERICA DOES
WHAT WE ASK FOR OVER THE NEXT 15
DAYS, WE WILL SEE A DRAMATIC
DIFFERENCE AND WE WON’T HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT THE VENTILATORS, WE
WON’T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT THE
ICU BEDS, BECAUSE WE WON’T HAVE
OUR ELDERLY AND/OR PEOPLE OF THE
GREATEST RISK HAVING TO BE
HOSPITALIZED.
>> Shannon: EVERY COUNTRY IS
DIFFERENT BUT SOME ARE MORE
AUTHORITARIAN IN NATURE, OTHERS
ARE MORE FREEWHEELING.
WE’VE SEEN DIFFERENT RESULTS IN
PLACES LIKE JAPAN, SOUTH KOREA
TO ITALY AND SPAIN.
DO YOU THINK WHAT WE ARE DOING
RIGHT NOW WITH THE SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND THE CANCELING OF
ALL THESE MAJOR EVENTS AND NOW
EVEN SMALLER, SMALLER GROUPS AND
EVENTS IS GOING TO BE ENOUGH TO
FLATTEN THAT CURVE?
>> I THINK IS VERY AGGRESSIVE
AND IS A VERY APPROPRIATE.
I BELIEVE IT WILL AS LONG AS
PEOPLE COOPERATE IN WAYS THAT WE
ASK FOLKS TO DO THAT.
THERE ARE A LOT OF YOUNG PEOPLE,
DR. BURRIS ALSO SAID IT’S THE
MILLENNIALS WHO MAKE THE
DIFFERENCE IN TERMS OF SLOWING
THE SPREAD OF THE DISEASE, THE
PEOPLE MOST VULNERABLE, IF THEY
ARE IN CONTACT, ARE OUR SENIORS,
PEOPLE WHO ARE OLDER, WHO ALSO
HAVE UNDERLYING MEDICAL
CONDITIONS.
THAT’S WHY THE SOCIAL DISTANCING
IS SO VERY IMPORTANT.
WE LOOK AT SOUTH KOREA, THAT IS
THE MODEL THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE FOR THE UNITED STATES
RATHER THAN WHAT WE SAW IN WUHAN
AND SEEING THEM IN ITALY AND
ACROSS EUROPE.
>> Shannon: SENATOR, WE WISH
YOU ALL THE BEST AS YOU WORK ON
THESE NEW PACKAGES IN THE COMING
DAYS IN THIS IMPORTANT TIME.
>> PEOPLE’S LIVES HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED, LIVELIHOODS HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED LIKE NOTHING THEY’VE
EVER SEEN BEFORE.
THE GOVERNMENT HAS A ROLE IN
PROVIDING RELIEF FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AT THIS TIME.